[موسيقى]
هل يمكن ان يكون لكل شخص ملاكه الحارس
الالكتروني الخاص به تخيل لو انه بامكانك
الحصول على جميع المعلومات التي تخص
سلامتك وان يكون لديك احدا يحميك هذا ما
قدمته شركه افايا في معرض جايتكس لهذا
العام الفكره من ورا المراك الحارس هي اذا
في عندي اي سكورتي سيستم في العماره
كاميرات درون روبات اي اي شيء في عليه
كاميرا ممكن اوصل هذا الفيد للموظف على
جهاز بكون على ايده يعني بكون ممكن موبايل
فون او ممكن يكون اي جهاز ل موظفي الطوارئ
فهو وهو ماشي في العماره بكون عارف شو في
قدامه وشو في وراه بحيث انه لا سمح الله
في صر حريق وراه او حريق قدامه يقدر يتحرك
بطريقه
امنه كما قدمت افايا ايضا باقتها الخاصه
بالشركات والاعمال بعنوان المكتب
الذكي المكتب الذكي هي فكره احنا وصلنا
لها عشان نبسط الطريقه الناس بيستخدموا
فيها
انظمه الفيديو والتليفونات حطينا كل
السيستم غرف الاجتماعات والتليفونات
والفيديو كونفرنس بسيستم واحد فانا بدخل
على المكتب ضروري اسال لا سكرتيره ولا
اسال حدا بعمل سكان للباتش المعلومات من
الباش بطلع لي مباشره بتقوللي مثلا غرفه
الاجتماعات ثلاثه موجوده بتحب تحجزها ققول
لله يي احجزلي اياها بعد ما احجز
الغرفه بتتحكم بالاضاءه بتحكم بالتكييف
بتحكم بانظمه الاتصال الفيديو اللي موجوده
في غرفه الاجتماعات بث لما اوصل على غرفه
يكون كل السيستم جاهزي بستخدم ه الغرفه
خلال مثلا ساعه ساعتين خلصت اجتماعاتي
بعمل تشيك او من السيستم يعني بطلع انا من
السستم اوتومات بصلني عن الفيديو بطفي
الاضاءه وبيطفي التكييف بترجع الغرفه
بتكون موجوده لاي شخص ب يستخدمها الحمايه
والامن وسهوله الحياه اليوميه عناوين
اساسيه ترتبط بتغلغل التكنولوجيا بعمق
اكبر في حياتنا اليوميه بلس ابراهيم
لسانان بالعربيه من معرض جايتكس دبي